[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: You can't really
talk about storage at Google
without talking about how
our production systems work.
How are all the
hard disks and flash
drives on individual
machines connected?
Let's boil it down.
Data is stored in hard disk
drives or solid state drives.
SSDs and HDDs are
deployed separately
from the applications.
For example, they can be
stored in a dedicated storage
tray like this one.
In other words, we separate
Storage from Compute.
Data needed by a
machine is typically
not even in the same
rack because machines
can access data in a
different physical location
through our robust
global fiber network.
Splitting Storage and
Compute lets us scale them
independently as demand grows.
And machines can process
requests much more efficiently.
We organize Storage
and Compute racks
into rows of
physical enclosures,
organizing groups of
enclosures into clusters,
and putting multiple clusters
in a single data center.
Each cluster depends on their
own power, cooling, and network
infrastructure,
a deliberate part
of how we design for data
protection and reliability
at scale.
We've built our own
warehouse-scale machine out
of hundreds of thousands
of relatively inexpensive
machines.
At Google, it's rare to
dedicate an entire storage
appliance in our data
center for storing only one
product or service's data.
Instead, we spread a workload's
data across multiple machines,
and workloads share network
access to that storage.
Encryption is inherent
in our storage systems,
and all data is encrypted
prior to being written to disk.
But how does Google make
storage accessible and scalable
across a global
fleet of machines?
Remember, at
planetary scale, it's
not unusual for individual
machines, racks,
or even entire buildings
to periodically fail,
so we need to build software
to make the data stored on them
durable.
That way, when they
fail, no data is lost.
Every layer of
our storage stack,
down to the file system and the
layer that writes to storage
devices, is a shared service.
Services like Search,
Photos, and Gmail
workloads share machines
at the data centers.
Resources within each machine,
like Compute and Memory,
are allocated to each service.
At a machine level,
disk, or D for short,
is a system that exposes
the hard disk and SSD drives
attached to individual
machines to other services
in the cluster.
It manages access to each
machine's disk capacity
to maximize utilization.
At the cluster level,
most data we store
has high durability and
latency requirements,
so we built a file system called
Colossus on top of D, which
is the foundation for many
services like Cloud Storage
and Bigtable.
At the Colossus level,
files are broken down
into a set of chunks that can
be stored on different machines
in the cluster.
This data replication
across machines
is the key to fast
recovery and fault
tolerance against things
like network failures.
For a given chunk, Colossus
identifies a machine
to write the chunk to, and
the client sends the chunk
to the D service that
runs on the target machine
to perform the write.
Security is ensured through
the encryption of each chunk,
and each chunk has a
unique encryption key.
Because a single machine can
be running multiple services,
and conversely, a service can
be running on many machines,
services are constantly
adapting to the amount
of resources they use.
Now you can see how distributed
data better utilizes
our machine capacity and gives
Google Cloud Services higher
reliability and performance.
For Google Cloud users,
you have the option
to store data on local
solid state drives,
zonal persistent disks that
map to clusters across zones
in the same region, or
regional persistent disks
across cloud regions or
even storage buckets.
You can store data in a single
region for high performance,
dual region for high performance
and high availability,
and multiple regions for
the highest availability.
Your data maps to
different clusters
and protects it from zonal
and regional failures.
D and Colossus manage access to
the storage, store data safely
and securely, and
efficiently use our hardware
so you get the best
performance possible.
All of this is possible because
of the speed of our network
fabric.
More on that next time on
Discovering Data Centers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]